I'm talking about validating big data
and ml pipelines I mostly work in spark
with a little bit of beam so that's
where the examples are from but these
techniques should apply regardless of
the tools that you're using and the the
full title is avoiding awkward
recommendations and this comes from
sometimes when I've made some awkward
recommendations in my life and I'm not
talking about Bud Light Lime so my name
is Holden my preferred pronouns are she
her it's tattooed on my wrist which is
really convenient in the mornings when
life is a little fuzzy I'm a developer
advocate at Google this is nice they pay
me money
and I checked my work email I still work
there and I'm on the spark PMC which is
like being a committer but it is really
hard to get rid of me now so that's
exciting I like to think of it like
tenure but then my friends point out
that I don't get paid for that so it's
not real tenure and I also contribute to
beam and some other stuff I've worked at
a bunch of companies and I'm a co-author
of two books on spark the the more
recent one has a much better royalty
deal and so I strongly recommend that
book it it's not a good intro book but
I'll make more money on it
and you can follow me on Twitter slides
if anyone's really curious about how
large open-source projects do code
reviews I started doing live streams of
them when I was informed that I needed
to make a bunch of video content but
also I think they're fun and hopefully I
can trick some of you into helping me
review more open source PRS because we
have 500 open pull requests and I don't
have that kind of time
and if you've got feedback on this talk
there's a link at the bottom you can
fill it out if you have questions
there's a slider thing so far none of
the talks I've been and I've actually
had questions coming on it maybe you
will today maybe you won't that's fine
okay musicians who I am professionally I
am
and clear Canadian in America and h-1b
work visa it's a really fun time to be
here on an h-1b work visa and part of
other community and this is perhaps not
directly related to distributed systems
there is no secret Canadian garbage
collector we've been hiding from you if
there was I would try and sell it to you
but yeah I think it's useful to remember
that we come from different places and
and to talk about that and if we realize
that all of the people we have solving a
problem do not come from different
places maybe that is time to see if we
need a different team so that we don't
just make yesterday's biases stronger
with computers because that would be
really sad and yeah I don't want that
that's why you should yeah okay anyways
so I'm gonna cover a few different
things we're gonna talk about property
testing as a lead-in to validation we'll
talk about what validation is on these
pipelines why you should do it simple
rules for validation some of the
constraints that we live in in these
systems and then I'll do some more
talking about ml specific things really
curious how many people here do machine
learning he's tough okay how many people
use spark yay how many people use beam
okay desk
that's exciting
um does anyone oh okay one person is
very excited for task yes um does anyone
use another data pipelining system that
I didn't mention that they flink oh I'm
so sorry
yes plank most excellent anyone else
okay cool well so the nice thing about
all of those systems is we can apply the
same techniques and the only part that
you have to do is change your code that
part just that's easy right so that's
great so I'm hoping you're nice people
you laughed at my shady intro jokes so
we're good if you don't like pictures of
cats this is
the talk for you there are many other
talks happening it is alright if you
want to leave no worries I'm hoping
you're familiar ish with one of Scala
Java or Python and if you're not and
something doesn't make sense you don't
have to wait until the end you can stop
me and we can explain the syntax and I'm
hoping you want to make better software
if you don't then maybe your boss wants
you to make better software I don't know
alternatively you're just here because
you're like me early in my career when I
was like oh oh I need to test this stuff
or I'm gonna get fired and then that's a
pretty good thing too
I enjoy not having to try and transfer
my work visa so yeah okay whoa
so why should we test um it makes us a
better person avoid making users
language etc etc since you're here you
probably already care about testing but
if there are other people in your
organization who don't you can remind
them of the exciting fun of having your
ml jobs fail on our 26
yay and we don't have recoverable
checkpoints yeah okay and so not only
will it save you money it'll it'll save
you time okay why don't we validate so I
think there's a lot of good reasons
oh sorry why should we validate the
first one is your test coverage is
probably not perfect I am lazy and tests
are one of the things which may
occasionally get left by the wayside we
can find ourselves in situations where
there is a part of our code which is
just really really hard to test or even
even if we do manage to have good test
coverage we may not actually cover all
of the wonderful kinds of data that the
real world is gonna come up for us with
and at some point we are going to be
aboard the fail boat that is just a fact
of software engineering eventually we
all fail
hopefully we fail together with a team
so
lonely experience but it's better to
know when you're failing if you find out
when your customers call you that is
anxiety-provoking I found the other hand
your internal tools can tell you that
something has gone amiss before your
customers find out out of it your life
will be much better and you have a lot
less explaining to do and you can
pretend that your software works which
is really what we all want to do at the
end of the day is pretend that this
stuff works
okay so the other reason is a lot of
people will deploy their stuff
automatically into production that's
really great I'm glad you deploy your
models frequently into production but I
am terrified because I've been there and
I'm terrified because of the next slide
we're about 15 percent of people have
had a serious production outage and the
remaining I mean read it here 32 percent
had an outage that they didn't consider
serious per se which I take to mean they
didn't have to update their resume but
some customers were a little upset and
the remaining 52% are working on M&S dot
CSV there's nothing wrong with working
on I'm gonna stuff CSV but you're not
super likely to get a production outage
so okay why don't we test it's hard our
tests go slow you can take a lot of time
testing distributed systems is
particularly annoying I'm not gonna ask
you who had made if you don't test your
code that would be unfair but the other
part is notebooks how many people love
notebooks yay how many people love the
testing experience with notebooks yeah
um and so notebooks are amazing and I
think they've made data pipelines
accessible to a lot more people and that
is really good because I am lazy and
other people doing this work is the key
to me eventually retiring but if they do
it without tests it's the key to me
never retiring
and being sad all the time and I think
no books are really good but we maybe
need better tools around testing them I
don't have an answer to that part let's
just we're screwed but that's fine um so
we don't validate because we tell
ourselves our tests are good we think
what could go wrong in production and
then the other honest part of it at
least for me is that making validation
rules with distributed systems is a lot
harder right like if I'm collecting
metrics on one machine it's a lot easier
to write rules about like hey when you
see your CPU go to like 95 percent maybe
we should like take a look at that but
when I've got like 200 machines doing a
job together it's like work the other
one is that they're not always
deterministic which is just great
everyone loves the fact that we recover
from failures it's better than failing
but sometimes it's better than failing
um sometimes this this quasi non
determinism can make actually figuring
out what's going on hard and creating
correct alerting really difficult so
what happens when we don't now there is
a video camera so these stories will not
be mentioning any of the wonderful I
assure you small independent vendors
that I worked at when I was there by
name but we can talk about some of the
things in sort of the abstract some
words have multiple meanings some of
them are appropriate for minors and some
of them are not but the word is spelt
the same and that's that's okay if you
have a good system for flagging which
products you probably don't want to show
the small ones yes however if someone
changes the meaning of that field and
you don't have any validation on your
input data and all of a sudden all of
the products are available for everyone
you have a very exciting 15 minute SLA
to respond to is the other one oh you
know just straight up costing money
personally I would much rather lose my
employer money than how
to explain to people why we showed small
children things almost recommending
illegal content this was like the low
point of my career and we only got lucky
because we happened to spot check it
that day yay
and that that also came from a wonderful
cinema change and those listeners
there's people who have really great
tools to prevent schema changes without
you know refactoring all of the
downstream consumers of your data and I
think that's great and we should all do
it but what I've noticed is when you do
that people just change the meaning of
the field because changing the schemas
hard but what about if I just stopped
populating it I'll just not take it out
of the schema because then they have to
refactor everything but if everything
just becomes null that's really my
downstream consumers problem right the
only problem is there's a good chance
that you work at the same organization
and they may be able to find your desk
now thankfully I work for a mega Corp so
finding my desk can take some time and I
work from home but this could matter to
you oh right and there was another time
and this one was more funny because all
of my validation tests were written for
coffee shops because I like coffee a lot
and then I ran them and I was like
excellent all of our search results are
finding coffee shops just like they
should and I pushed it to production and
someone told me that Starbucks was not a
steakhouse I did debate that their new
breakfast sandwich offerings were food
of a sort but did not go anyways ok
so hopefully I've convinced you that
this is important if I haven't it's fine
you can just fall asleep there's also
the internet here it's very great for
distracting you if you don't want a
snore um so for tests I think one of the
things before we get too deep into
validation which we talk about is what
kind of data people test on because if
we're testing on our whole production
data
maybe maybe our tests are going to be a
good indicator of what production looks
like however that is
15% of people how many people here can
run their tests on their full production
data okay we've got one no - okay
we have four people one of whom is
probably how do I say optimistic in my
experiences I have certainly believed
that I was testing on my full production
data only to discover it later that
there was extra bits in real production
other people sample their production
data this is pretty good however that
that you might find that you have these
really weird corner cases that can
really screw up your recommendation
systems and yeah okay right property
checks how many people are familiar with
property check King for testing yay
property based tests are amazing I like
them because I don't have to come up
with examples and if people ask you know
I'm not all that creative except when it
comes to my wardrobe which you know
purple dinosaur is a good sample test
but for for actual data test I'm like
well let's try no and the number six but
it's big data so we'll try the number
one two three and six but it turns out
that we need to use 1 million entries
oh okay it's not that I'm old it's just
that people didn't find the joke funny
that's fine so we can write property
checks and we can ensure that our
important business logic function does
not drop any records right and we can
write other things like this and the
nice thing about these property checks
is we can actually start to flip them on
their head and consider how we can use
them as validation rules right like if
we know we have a thing which should not
lose any records well that's a good
thing that we could be asserting at
production or maybe not asserting
because assertions are scary but at the
very least logging to a file for someone
to ignore okay oh yeah and it turns out
that if you actually want to do property
checking with 1 million entries it gets
a little slow and there's a bunch of
things you can do to speed it up I'll
post the slides later if anyone's
curious about that so let's focus on the
main point of the talk which is
validation and all kinds of fun so how
do we do this
the idea is and I think to a degree at
one point your software worked right
validation is not gonna help us really
in the case where our software has never
worked but if we're in the case where
like it used to work and we want to make
sure it keeps working for at least the
tenure of our employment validation is a
great tool there maybe we manually
tested it maybe I tried searching for
more than coffee shops you know I search
for coffee shops and steak houses and I
got two results that were not Starbucks
so it was good to shape to production
but we can't do manual checking every
time in part because a lot of our
companies fired all of their manual
testers yay quality this is being
recorded so it all showed up but you
know and the other part is that people
expect faster turnaround is now right
like in the days of like taking a week
to train a model adding an extra day to
let it sit and have someone look at head
and be like I wonder what this says
about take a chew let's see was like an
acceptable delay but when we're updating
our model daily
people don't like an extra day of delay
for you to be like I bet there's
something silly about Pikachu in here
it's no longer an acceptable solution
okay so how many people have some code
in their data pipeline that looks
something like this you've taken a
record you try and parse it and if you
fail well let's just drop the record
it's JSON so it was probably just
malformed am I the only person who
writes bad code here no okay there's a
lot of people and some laughter with a
conspicuously not raised hands from
large companies and that's fine that's
fine so I'm going to assume that maybe
maybe you don't have JSON data maybe you
have X amount it's fine I worked at IBM
- and next time all is lovely but
occasionally we might get parse errors
and that's that's okay right if we
failed our data pipeline every time we
encountered a problem with a single
record there is a good chance that we
would not have a data pipeline or we
would have a very nice decorative piece
but we would not have any production
ready models and so we end up writing
code like this and that's okay some of
the time but unfortunately if we if we
don't produce any data we will normally
notice and that's exciting and if our
model is empty our cat will be very
hungry and this will be very sad the
empty cat food bowl is not a good ALS
predictor so we can we can validate you
know we can filter we can write some
rules then we can check the counts and
we can put some special business error
handling logic they're very special very
business it's a Motorola pager or
nowadays it's probably paid your duty
but the same psychological effects on
your team okay so um the other part is
who who wants to write their code to
look like this every time they're doing
something which might accept some of the
records i've got like one person who was
like yeah yeah i do this but now they're
shaking their heads so I'm not
I don't know okay so part of it is
writing your code like that is less fun
the other part of it is by doing this we
tend to break the optimizers and a lot
of things and the other part is doing
this in a system like beam is actually
surprisingly complicated because it does
a whole program evaluation and so
getting intermediate counters out of it
can be quite challenging and so stopping
in the middle of your pipeline is pretty
much a no-go without an exception and
that's all kinds of sadness and so
generally this will make our job slower
and use more cloud computing resources
that being said I work at a cloud
provider so this is not all bad I'm like
I saw you CPUs by the hour
we're good but we can use counters
instead to the rescue and counters in in
spark are like our friends but the
friends who kind of took our lunch money
okay you all had much more healthy sort
of like early education experiences but
the nice thing is beam and spark have
their own counters implementation lots
of other things have their own counters
as well they track their own metrics but
we can add our own metrics on top of it
and we can pretend we're still writing
functional code because we won't put
that if statement in the middle we'll
hide it and that is like not having a
side effect right we just put it in
another file so that's what we'll do um
we'll take this and we'll we'll make a
happy counter in a sad counter and we'll
put our special business data logic
processing down there well we'll do the
processing and then at the end of our
job after we've waited 12 hours we'll
check to see if our data was good who
likes this approach this is damn tough
crouch um so the other one is we could
actually not save our validation
necessarily to the end some other people
do some nice things where what they do
is they essentially write code like this
except instead of running as part of
their main pipeline they have a data
quality checker that runs either
alongside in a separate processor on the
same
cluster to validate that your inputs are
actually reasonable you don't block your
main processing pipeline you can have
your ugly code in a separate file it'll
do its counts but it's it's separate and
it can still stop your job if it
realizes that 90% of your customer
records have been replaced with the word
cap right so that'll help to okay so
that being said oh I meant to change the
site we'll pretend that site didn't
exist okay okay anyway let's go back to
okay so um how many people have used
counters in spark or be more flanked
okay cool not a lot so before you do I
want to be clear that the counter is
stealing our lunch money wasn't just a
joke they're also really unreliable and
so it's a really great thing to use to
protect our data wait
okay um so oh yeah okay so you know the
the joke I have 99 problems but a very
real er expression and now I have an
uncountable number of problems but
that's that's okay counters are similar
because what will happen is you can
write your tests you can use counters
and then when you run your code locally
it'll look like it's working and that's
that's the best code is the code that
will behave differently on your laptop
and on the cluster and counters are that
code yay um that being said I don't have
anything better this is sad but it
essentially there's a reason that we
have to keep track of our successes and
our failures and that's because because
of how spark handles recomputation and
because beam has different engines which
handle counters in different ways and
because I don't actually know how flink
implements their counters we need to
essentially accept that the same data
may be processed multiple times just for
good measure and then we'll just count
it a few times
and so if we used absolute numbers if we
said like redirect more than 10,000
you know bad records there's a chance
that our 10,000 bad records could
actually be one record that was parsed
10,000 times yay um but if we do it as a
percentage it'll hopefully work out kind
of yeah yeah cross your fingers and push
the product okay um so what what do
other people do besides adding counters
to their to their data processing
according to a really depressing survey
that I run most people's only validation
rule is checking how long their pipeline
takes and the idea is if it takes a
really long time something has gone bad
and if it finishes really really quickly
you're either a genius programmer or
something has gone bad and in my
experience normally something has gone
bad and checking the execution time is
good the other one is we can check the
record counts this is especially useful
for those of you who work with web the
scale databases which may have flexible
memories and so if you see the number of
records all of a sudden decrease unless
you recently had some unfortunate press
or something that explains that that's
perhaps a good time to not push an
updated model into production and so
generally a lot of these things are
based on historical data right we we
have the idea that our pipeline used to
work and it working today should look
kind of like it working yesterday and
the other one is domain-specific
solutions and we'll talk about those in
the ml space all kinds of fun okay
and we can turn our property tests into
validation rules if you write property
based testing please consider doing that
it's nice the the one thing is the real
world can be a little bit fuzzier so had
some tolerances you know except that
someone is going to come and say that
their cat's name is null and their
favorite food is I don't know database
record type it's it's gonna happen um
and maybe you should stop your pipeline
but maybe if you only have six cats
named no that's okay
so we looked at input schema validation
with filter and flatmap
if you're the kind of person who says my
data must always be correct good job
I hope you have a lot of time on your
hands and you can aesthetically ask
spark or beam to make sure that all of
your data is correct and you can just
tell it this is the case class that
should represent my data these are the
constraints and then we'll do that and
throw an exception and then after a few
weeks you can get it to not throw an
exception but by then your data has
changed yeah okay yeah great okay great
and here's an example of relative rules
where we say if the bad values are more
than 10% of my import records maybe
someone should take a look
pick the percentage based on your data
formats and valued partners if you work
with people who send you CSV files to an
FTP server you might want to allow 20%
if you work with people who upload JSON
files to your website you might pick a
higher number or if you work with people
in house who have like my sequel
back-end you might pick a lower number
than 10% of your records being invalid
so you know your mileage may vary
um alright and here's an example we can
use sparks own built-in counters one of
its counters that it has is records red
if you go look in the spark web UI or in
the DM UI you can see all of the like
internal metrics that our data systems
are collecting it for us normally
nothing useful is done with these
metrics we just collect them because
we're like we're engineers we have to
collect metrics if I don't collect
metrics my an engineer the answer is yes
but it's alright and so you could
actually use these metrics that someone
has put there often at great expense and
yes special business logic always goes
at the bottom and you you have a lot of
fun okay oh and here's an example in
beam for people who like Java it's has
the angle Brett oh we know it doesn't
oops we'll move right oh okay
I thought I had angle brackets to 10
ohms for the Java people but just
pretend there's an alligator here I'll
replace this cat photo with an alligator
for next time and so we can say match
words and we can write our own counters
and then we can say you know the
unmatched words should not be less than
match words or some other kind of rule
another thing that you can do which I
don't recommend putting in your main
pipeline if you're going to follow this
approach I recommend putting it in a
separate sort of side pipeline is if you
keep historic versions of your data
around right if for example I have a
snapshot of yesterday's data anyways
because I do this thing called backups
maybe I could see if my data has changed
a lot since yesterday and a lot is based
on whatever doesn't wake you up once a
month but still is low enough it wakes
you up a few times a year right
you you want this to catch the things
and it will depend on your users and
what kind of data you're collecting
right for example my data about stuffed
animals changes on a week to week basis
as I collect more stuffed animals but
only by about two records per week and
so I can accept that kind of variation
but if I see a hundred records go down I
need to have a conversation with my wife
about returning the stuffed animals from
her room to my room and the same can be
true with your data sources well
normally someone hasn't stolen your data
they just make a copy of it that's a
different problem okay moving right
along the other one is hopefully you
saved your previous output
you're not just overwriting it live if
you are you have another problem but you
can write your output and you can check
to see
does today's output look like
yesterday's output this is really good
for ETL jobs it's really great doing it
for a model it's a little fuzzier but we
can look at this right and right not
just our data changes our software is
gonna change behind us too and you're
gonna want to catch that right and that
we can catch maybe more in looking at
the outputs and the execution time and
the counters there was this really
amazing PI data London talk that looked
at training the default models for a
bunch of scikit-learn models across the
different versions of scikit-learn
without changing any of the data and the
model performance it was not like this
it did not go up into the right
it went up down up discontinuous because
it failed and then like and it's just
even if you're just upgrading simple
packages you may find thinkwell
scikit-learn is not a simple package but
if you're if you're just upgrading small
things you can find really big changes
and often for the better but you should
check because sometimes it is not yeah
let's talk about ml um so just because
we're doing machine learning doesn't
mean that we don't need to validate our
data it is really important we validate
our data because it's less clear on the
other side what's happening with it we
got some new things to check it's pretty
cool
that being said some of our old things
probably aren't so great anymore the
output size of my model is probably not
going to vary a whole lot provided I'm
training the same kind of model some
exceptions apply and eyeballing the
results is a lot harder right and I'm
not saying that you you should be
eyeballing your results all of the time
but with validation rules when it goes
wrong a lot of us just end up kind of
like going and looking at the table I
mean like these six records look okay
let's go look at some of the other
rejected records that we save to Kafka
and then we'll go look and it'll be like
oh no it's fine they're all rejected but
um going and looking at some weights I
don't have a lot of intuition
as to you know if this hybrid feature
has changed a lot that doesn't doesn't
tell me a lot if the model weights are
shifting for this one feature I have to
like sit and think about it for a while
I can't just kind of guess I mean I can
but it will go poorly okay so how do we
traditionally deploy our models a human
decides it's time to update their model
they have a really well-written run book
that tells them how to update their
model they read it they do it it doesn't
fail human deploys their model to some
percentage of their users we observe the
users do not die we deploy it to all of
our users it's great and we pressed
apply so but in practice what happens is
human is cornered by their stakeholders
and forced to update their models
because that's probably not what they
get promoted for I have a small amount
of cynicism maybe just in case you
haven't guessed spend a few are trying
to remember where the guide is find out
that you didn't write the guide but like
you've got this ipython notebook and
you're pretty sure it's what you use to
build it it's cut untitled underscore
three to ipython notebook but like you
don't have an underscore for so it's
probably the right one and so you go you
run that and it gives you a model and
you're like well is some model deploy it
to some percentage of users you read
reddit or hacker news or your preferred
way to make yourself feel bad in the
morning I personally choose Twitter it
was really great this morning and then
whatever it's fine press to press deploy
no one died yet right if they died they
would have called me if it was if it was
important we'd be fine I don't have to
look at grass so for the new possible
practice for some people is that at some
point you've realized that your
stakeholders know where your desk is and
they keep finding you and asking you to
update your model and that is not what
you get promoted for so you write a
shell script to do it for you
and you run the synchron on a single
laptop because life is terrible so sorry
you know you use a workflow tool very
fancy notices new data is available oh
wait no no no we we did use the shell
script it's the workflow tool which is
for notices there's a new model for us
and automatically puts that into
production yeah it's great
remember that slide about people that
did that I really should have asked the
intersection of people who have their
jobs deployed into production what the
percentage was of the failures but I
recorded those numbers separately to try
and anonymize it a little but that was
angry sigh I wish I knew but I imagine
the overlap between people who to deploy
automatically to production and
production outages is nonzero I'm
computer deploys it to some percentage
of models you have metrics about what
your users are doing you know just that
they're actively engaging with your site
more you're really excited you're a
Silicon Valley company engagement is the
only metric you care about this is
recorded robot okay so it's the
monitoring graphs and sees that actually
it's not good all of your users left
you're sad sad users robot rolls it back
your pager goes off your life is sad
human press is over right anyways
deploys to production your pager goes
off again okay great um oh yeah there
was no special part about okay um so
there there are different tools that you
can use for production monitoring and
you should use them
cube flow has some really nice built-in
tools if you're working within that
ecosystem different ecosystems have
their own specific tools and you should
actually do your monitoring on those
tools and you should write a robot that
rolls it back because the robot doesn't
have to wake up at 2:00 in the morning
and my life goal is to never carry a
Motorola pager again okay so here's our
extra considerations oh right some
people like to use a fixed test set
performance to measure if their model is
good this is really good provided that
the world does not change and so if if
you don't keep jobs for very long
fix test set is fine if you change jobs
less frequently than your users change
their behavior for example perhaps
Hannah Montana is not as cool I mean or
I feel old again
okay fine we can look at the number of
iterations and the convergence rate if
we have a large spike in the number of
iterations or if our convergence rate
even if we get really really good
numbers when we get unexpectedly good
numbers we should not deploy to
production either because that means
something has changed and once again
either we're a genius or our software is
terrible and I'll bet on the software
and you can look at the deltas in your
model weights if they don't tend to
shift that much and you have something
where it's easy to look at the model
weights that's okay
I have not deployed systems like that
personally
instead I look at the number of teachers
that were selected and and stuff like
that you can manager your
cross-validation performance on your
actual training data a lot of people use
this to Autotune
as well if you do that you're just you
know overfitting with cross-validation
so don't do that I mean it's a good way
to get impressive looking numbers but
not actual performance right so I want
to be clear even if our our validation
tells us that everything is good
cross-validation is happy and it says
we're gonna make tons of money oh and
I'm gonna wrap it up um yep it can still
go wrong and you'll still have to find
someone and trick them into carrying a
pager
okay um serving is terrible updating
your model sucks ending notes everything
is terrible it's okay don't feel bad
there are some tools to make your life
less bad but not all that much less bad
there's a reason they pay us money for
these jobs here's a bunch of related
resources I'll tweet them so you
I didn't actually put the URLs in them
anyway so it's useless
there's some related packages I did put
the URLs don't yeah but I'll tweet this
as well oh and I cannot skip the most
important slide high-performance part is
the best spark book that I have written
and it pays the highest royalties of any
book I have written if you have an
expense account please buy several
copies okay oh and if you're excited in
teaching your children or other people's
children with their permission
distributed computing I would encourage
you to check out distributed computing
for kids.com i I think it will be fun
and yeah I want to write a children's
book and this seemed like a way to maybe
trick my boss into paying me to do that
if it doesn't work out I'll just write
it on the weekend though and yeah so
this is the second most important slide
this is the most important slide and
then we're done hmm oh cool
I think we're literally out of time but
I'll be here and I'm wearing a pink
dinosaur dress so you can come and find
me thank you all
[Applause]